字幕: Naohide Hirano
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
(拍手)
皆さん
つい一杯一杯と言ってしまう時は
ないでしょうか
忙しい時
人なら誰でも言いたくなる
と思います
ですが 一杯一杯ですと
やはり忙しい時
そして
そっとしておいてほしい時
いろんな時にこう言いたくなる
タイミングがあると思います
ただ 皆さんちょっと
考えてみて欲しいんですね
自分が今から
話しかけようとする相手が
一杯一杯です　とか言ってきたりですとか
あとは明らかに一杯一杯である
オーラ 雰囲気を出している時
皆さん どのように思いますか
今すぐ何か話しかけようと思いますか
あなたにとって大事な経験や秘密を
話そうと思いますか
距離を縮めて
積極的に今 コミュニケーションを
取ろうと思いますか
周囲の人はそういったものを
敏感に受け止めます
一杯一杯だという言葉を聞いた その時
もしくは そういった雰囲気を感じた時に
多くの方は ちょっと今話し掛けるのを
やめておこうとか
距離を取っておこうとか
大事な話はまた今度にしようとか
そのように思うことが多いと思います
ただ そうしてしまうことによって
相手から学びを得る機会
話を得る機会というものを
失ってしまいます
なので 非常にちょっと
ネガティブなことだと思うんですね
ですので 私は
一杯一杯という言葉を使うことを
やめました
私は今から一杯一杯にならないために
私の中で考えてやってきたこと
そして それをやっていくことによって
得られた閃きやアイデア
そして それを行動に
どの様に繋げたかといった所を
そのプロセスを
お話させて頂きたいと思います
今お話したように
一杯一杯で人との関りを
受け入れられない
情報が入ってこないという状態を
作り出すこと自体は
すごくもったいないことだと
私は考えています
その瞬間を どうしても
人によってはできてしまう
そうなってしまう方も
いらっしゃるとは思うんですが
できれば
たとえ大変な時であっても
この人との関わり合い
そして 情報が入ってくる
という状態は
常に持っておくべきだと思います
なかなか難しいことだとは思うのですが
そして それと併せて
私のこれ
考えなんですが
人との関係性を構築する上で
私はフラットであること
というのを重視しています
あくまで私の場合ですが
人と適度な距離感を持って
関係を構築することをまずひとつ目
そして
相手の立場などによって
態度を変えない
そこは普段から意識してというか
自然とそういうことを
やるようになってきました
その結果だと思うんですが
比較的フラットに付き合って
人間関係を作ってきたことによって
若干人より多めの
人的ネットワークというものが
構築出来たのかな
というふうに思います
そして そのフラットな人間関係と幅広く
コミュニケーションを取る
関係を構築出来たことによって
いろんな話を
いただけるようになりました
話 具体的に言うと情報です
先程から情報 情報と言っていますが
今日 私がこの場で
お伝えしたい情報というのは
一つ定義がありまして
今スマホで検索すれば
どんな情報でも簡単に手に入ります
ただ 私が今言いたい情報は
実際 リアルなコミュニケーションを
通じてしか得られない
そして 世の中に出回っていない
一部の人の中で共有されている
経験や学び 課題
そういったものを情報
とお話ししたいと思います
そして 私が一杯一杯にならないために
やってきたことも
少しお話をさせてください
今 こちらにコップがあります
なんてことのない普通のコップを
イメージしてください
そして 大きな器ですね
子供が入るぐらいの
極端なサイズのもの
とだけイメージしてください
あなたの今横にあります
この器が横にあります
そして 目の前に湧き水があります
例え話ですが 今大きな器に
あなたは
水を溜めなければいけないとします
皆さんどうしますか
難しい話ではなくて
コップで湧き水を汲んで
この大きな器に移していきます
この器に移していくことによって
湧き水を
常に自分の手元において
使いたい時に 使いたい量だけ
使えるようになります
大変抽象的なお話ですが
私が以前からやってきたのが
まさにこれだと思います
水というのは情報です
そしてコップ
これは 一時的に情報を受け止める
ちっちゃな領域
記憶領域だと思います
一時的に受け入れる場所
そして器
これは頭の奥にある
普段は使わないんですけど
大量な情報 経験を詰め込む記憶領域
だと思ってください
この情報 水を器に移し替えていく
そして 一旦コップを空にすること
この情報を移し替える作業
ここが非常に重要なものだと
私は考えています
情報を移し替えていくことによって
いったん頭がリセットされて
整理されて また新しい情報を
受け入れられるようになります
今 このコップですが
これは俗にキャパシティーが
大きい小さいと言われるように
どうしても個人差というのはある
と思うんですね
ただ それほど大きな差はないと
私は考えています
それよりも大事なのが
先程の情報の移し替え作業
これはつまりリセット
そして もっと平たく言うと
「頭を真っ白にする瞬間を作り出すこと」
これが非常に重要で
一杯一杯の状態になってしまって
この作業が出来ないと
全く情報が自分の中に溜まらない
いつか使うかもしれない
貴重な情報が
ストックされない
ということになってしまいます
私はこの頭を真っ白にする
この作業を大事に考えてきました
具体的に私のパターンですが
私の場合は
例えばランニングをしているときに
今日は体が重くて全然走れないなとか
今日は軽いから
もう１キロ ２キロいけるなとか
あとじゃあ ２つ先の信号まで
ちょっとペースを上げて走ろうとか
ちょっと歩こうかなとか
走ることだけを
考えるようになります
その
走ることだけ考えるようになる
普段は仕事のこと
事業のこと 家族のこと
また プライベートのこと
いろいろいろんなことが
頭の中をぐるぐる巡っているんですね
でも その瞬間だけは
走ることだけを考えるようになります
その普段考えている思考から
全く違う思考に持って行く
この瞬間が私は
頭が真っ白になる瞬間だと思っています
そして 私の場合ですが
この真っ白になった後に
閃きが訪れることがあるんですね
ちょっとその先の話に
行きたいと思います
頭を真っ白にして
ときどき訪れる閃きがあります
大きな器の話をしましたが
そこに水が溜まっています
そこを見ますと
ちょっとキラリと
光る石ころが転がっている
原石ですね
それを見つけてきます
それを拾い出して
１個はそんなに
きれいじゃないんですけど
重ね合わせた瞬間に
光を増すことがあります
これが私は閃きであり
アイデアの
源泉 原石 原案が生まれた瞬間だと
考えています
原石はそのままでは使えません
どんどんアイデアを
磨いていく作業が必要になります
ここで私がいつも考えているのが
まずは自分でとことん考えること
そして
チーム 仲間でとことん議論すること
この２つは当たり前に
大事なことだと思います
ただ 私はもう１個
大事な要素があると
考えていて
「そのアイデアを相手に伝えること
アウトプットしていくこと」
そこが大事だと思っています
アウトプットすることで
自分の考えを整理して
そして 伝える力を磨いて
正確に相手に伝える
そして それを聞いた相手は
必ず感想を言ってくれます
その感想がフィードバックです
アウトプットとフィードバック
この２つがすごく重要で
フィードバックの中に
次のアイディアの原石が
たくさん入っています
そして フィードバックも
時々トンチンカンなフィードバックもあります
ただ トンチンカンな
フィードバックだからといって
後でよく考えてみると
なるほど 示唆に富んでいる
ワードが入っていたり
普遍的な何かが入っていたり
ということがある
そういったものを
見つける作業と
磨いていく作業
この２つが
私は大事なんだな
というふうに思っています
そしてアイデアを
どんどん磨いていくことによって
もともとはゴツゴツしていたアイデアが
だんだん輝きを増して
価値が高まっていきます
宝石の工程でいうと
原石から研磨を経て
宝石になっていきます
そして価値がつきます
アイディアも同じで
研磨をしていくことによって
実現可能性も同時に高まって
価値も高まっていきます
実現可能性を最大化した後は
あとは 自分で行動するのみです
今までお話ししてきたこと
私が一杯一杯にならないために
やってきたこと
そして 閃きを誘発するために
を踏まえて
私のケースを
お話をさせてもらいます
私は数年前まで
会社員をしていました
そのときのお話ですが
私は数年間ですね
社内のシステム開発担当を
兼任してやっていた時期があります
そのときに 会社から
社内のとあるシステムを開発をしろ
というミッションがあり
私はその中でプロダクトマネジャーとして
動いた経験がありますが
そのミッションをもらったときに
単純に社内の仕組みを
作るだけでは
何か面白くないな
ちょっと物足りないなという
ちょっとモヤモヤした気分が
そのときあったんです
そのモヤモヤを解消するために
私が以前から構築してきた
フラットなコミュニケーションで
構築してきた
人的ネットワークを使って
いろんな立場の人
社外の人 いろんな人に
ヒアリングをして回りました
少しアイデアが固まってきたときも
フィードバックをもらいたいので
説明をして
またフィードバックを
集めていきました
そういった形で
どんどん情報を溜め込んでいきます
ストックしていきました
やはりいろいろ忙しいものですから
一杯一杯になりそうな
瞬間っていうのはあるんですね
そのときに私は
先ほど申し上げたように
ランニングをしたり
趣味の筋トレをしたり
いろいろ頭を真っ白にする
プロセスというのを
意識的にやってきました
それでしばらくたった後ですね
こう ふっと
自宅にいるときに
閃いたものがありまして
社内システムを作るという
発想ではなくて
同業他社も欲しがるような
業界の課題解決に繋がるような
システムを作ったら
次のビジネスに繋がるんじゃないか
というのが ふっと閃いたものでした
そこからまた
そのアイデアを持って
いろいろ いろんな所へ
ヒアリングをして
フィードバックをもらって
というプロセスを繰り返して
だんだんアイデアが
輝きを増して
最終的には同業他社数社から
このシステムを買いたいという
オファーを頂いたり
納入した社内の営業マンからの評価も
非常にいいシステムを
作ることが出来ました
子供の頃は
いろいろ夢にあふれて
あれもやりたい こうなりたい
あったと思うんです
ただ だんだん成長とともに
現実が見えてきて
今の状況から
少し飛び出しづらくなる
これは誰もがありますし
私もそうでした
ただ 今人生は100年時代と
言われてます
そして いろんなことを始めるための情報
そしてSNSも発達して
いろんな方と繋がり易い時代になっています
そういったものを使って
もし今日 私のお話の中で
持ち帰って頂けるものがありましたら
少し一杯一杯になりそうなときに
どうするかとか
そのアイデアの原案を見つけるための
プロセスを少し真似してみて
貰いたいなと思います
実際は 皆さんそれぞれのやり方がある
と思いますけども
そうやって心がけることによって
自分の可能性 ご自身の可能性を
広げられるのではないかなと
私は思います
最後になりますが
私の今の職業はアントレプレナーです
2019年に
立ち上げた
VR技術を使ったスタートアップ企業を
今経営をしています
私も40歳で起業して
元々夢だった起業を叶え
ただ今はですね
その先の目標に向かって
会社の成長と自分の成長を
実現出来るように
今挑戦をし続けています
今後も閃きと
アイデアの創出をしていくために
水を器に移し替え続けたい
と思います
(拍手)